creeps and listeners guess what the  podcast is turning one they grow up so  fast grow fast that's right our first  anniversary is coming up and we are  celebrating in a big way with a live  show spectacular oh a live show  Absolutely that's always fun and here's  the good news the show is being streamed  live on moment okay so no matter where  you are you can come celebrate with us  when's the Show streaming November 16th  November 16th that's a Wednesday that's  a Wednesday 9 p.m eastern time well  that's also 6 p.m Pacific time that's  how time zones Wednesday November 6th  and it's 8 P.M Central Time and 7 P.M  mountain time it's at your time based on  the 9 p.m eastern time yeah you can  figure it out all right so here's where  are you gonna get the tickets you're  gonna go to moment.co always sunny and  we will see you there and guys it's  gonna be live streamed so that means we  can't cut that cut back we can drink now  yeah  foreign